Good afternoon, everyone.
Today, I'm going to talk to you about securing
websites in the early web, and telling you
a few funny stories about people having their
days profoundly ruined.
Before I start, I'm on Twitter tell me what
you think about the talks because I love getting
feedback from people.
In case moving images on big screens make
you feel uncomfortable, content warning will
appear on the bottom right hand corner of
my slides.
Come and see me later on if you want a sticker.
Say I believe hello.
I wanted to shout on the something I'm passionate
about.
I love volunteering at Scotland JS.
If you fancy coming to a conference that is
there and walk up a mountain during your lunch
break, that is exactly where our venue is.
It's really beautiful.
You should totally come along and get yourself
a ticket.
I came to the web like a lot of people through
fandom.
If you were here and watched Rachel White's
talk last year, you will know exactly what
I'm talking about.
So fans meet other fans through forums, through
web forums, where you can log in and stay
up in the early hours of the web, discussing
your favourite characters.
Post-signatures used to be a common site.
You used to use them to share your fandom
and show off your skills, a way of creatively
expressing yourself, and for many, an introduction
into web design and development — this is
how I learned HTML.
You could add them to your post by writing
HTML.
It was my first introduction of messing with
other people's sites, and you could do things
like HTML bombs.
That is where you deliberately or accidental
ly — technical stuff, folks.
Is that good?
Excellent.
Round of applause for the tech support people.
[Applause].
So you could mismatch HTML and create HTML
bombs.
This was accidental at first but lots of people
used it deliberately.
And maliciously.
They inserted mismatched HTML to make content
disappear off the side of the screens or make
it completely unreadable altogether.
This is caused by writing code that trusts
any old crap that the user sends to you which
is otherwise known as bad input validation.
There was another forum around about this
time dedicated to the animal crossing games,
and animal crossing, if you've not played
it before, is an idyllic game filled with
a town of peaceful people just getting along
and trading, so really lovely, idyllic game.
But this forum had a page that allowed you
to edit your profile, change your user name
and password, and someone discovered that
there is a hid en input field that contained
the user ID of the person's profile that you're
editing.
So someone thought what happens if I changed
that ID to the owner of that forum and make
it user ID1 and change the password?
I found out they could edit the profile of
any user on this forum.
Needless to say, this website devolved into
utter anarchy for a few days until it was
fixed.
There aren't any rules of making web development,
but if there were, I would make this one the
first rule: never trust user input, never,
ever trust user input!
Always ask yourself how even the nicest people
playing the nicest game in the universe can
misuse your code for fun and profit, because
they will.
How can I help protect yourself against bad
input validation?
You can use a library like joi to validate
your data on the backend to make sure that
the data is exactly what it appears to be
— make sure it is the right type and the
right length.
You can check a user's actions against their
identity as well to check what actions that
they can take, and whose data they can take
it on.
For instance, it should not be possible for
a new registered user to change the profile
of the owner of the forum, as we just saw.
Never, ever rely on client-side validation
alone.
It is a convenience to the user, and absolutely
nothing else.
It's not a security measure.
[Scattered laughter].
[Laughter].
For my next story, many forums on the early
web allowed to you log in using a login form
just like this, so you could enter your user
name and password, and it would save you from
having to enter these on the — many were
vulnerable to an attack with one unique password.
You could log in as any user you chose.
This attack allowed users to run their own
database queries on your site which is otherwise
known as SQL injection.
When you fill out a user name and a password
in a login form like this, the credentials
submitted in these forms get filled in to
an SQL query that you can see on the right.
SQL is a popular language for querying databases.
This example checks users matching the user
name and the password.
If the database find a matching user, it grants
the user permission to log in.
Let's see what happens if you submit that
one weird password.
The databases has interpreted it as regular
SQL which has a sequence that we didn't expect.
This part of the query says, "Give me all
the users with the user name matching the
user name admin" and the pass all all 1=1.
This is like saying to the database, "This
makes the query match every single user in
the database" but the software is checking
for more than zero matches so it grants the
your permission to log in.
This is essentially saying to the database
give me all the users matching the user name
admin or whatever you've got, I'm not fussy.
SQL injection hands the keys the database
to your users.
It allows attackers to extraordinary access
to your website, to recover sensitive information
of your users, and to give themselves complete
control to your site.
One of the most famous examples was Drupalgeddon.
It affected every one under that version 7
number.
When you think how many use Drupal, it affects
a lot of sites.
It allows the attacker full control over the
website.
There is also some evidence to suggest that
attackers patched the original exploit after
breaching sites to make it appear as if those
sites had not been breached.
How can you help protect yourself against
SQL injection?
Don't use string for concatenation to build
queries.
Get help from tools that offer you paramaterised
Or you can use object relational mapping to
get excellent help from tool maintainers who
have done this before.
I want to tell a quick bonus story that has
nothing to do with the web, a game I used
to play called World of Warcraft.
You can take on big, big bosses, big monsters,
and once someone found that, by shooting a
fireball and running away, and shooting a
fireball and run away, they could tow a boss
across the continent to the capital city of
Stormwind.
They managed to get this boss called Lord
Kasak into StormWind, and, when he kills a
character, he heals himself and his maximum
HP increases.
Within a few hours of being in Stormwind,
the Lord Kasak was fundamentally immortal.
They had to roll the servers back to restore
people's accounts.
This is a good example of how you may not
need to breach a computer system in order
to wreak havoc.
[Laughter].
Another story about my time on Fantasy forums,
I was looking at conversation about whether
certain characters were resurrectable, and,
suddenly, I was logged out.
I was presented with a login screen, and I
thought what is going on?
This wasn't happening to me but to other people
as well.
So I wonder what was causing this.
We tracked it down to one user with a broken
avatar.
We thought, "What's going on?"
Well, it turns out they had set the avatar
to logout.php so that any user who is looking
at this site would be logged out.
This is syntax that gets other users to do
your dirty work you, which is otherwise known
as cross-site request forgery.
Or CSRF for short.
Cross-site request forgery was successfully
exploited on the Netflix website.
This isn't the Netflix we have today, but
the old Netflix that used to post you DVDs
in order to watch at home.
This attack was possible without even injecting
any content into the Netflix website.
In fact, you could host this attack on your
site and just convince people to go to that
site.
We know that is possible because how many
times has this happened to you?
So, what if you could convince people to go
to your website?
And what if those people were logged into
Netflix?
In 2006, Dave Ferguson discovered a cross-site
request forgery in Netflix, a vulnerability
in Netflix, to put an image with that URL,
that URL adds a film of his choice to this
user's queue, sprinkle in a few requests to
change the account name, and to change the
shipping address, and you could ship yourself
free DVDs courtesy of whoever looked at your
website.
Cross-site request forgery exploits the trust
placed in users' browsers.
Why shouldn't Netflix trust these requests?
They come from legitimate users, the users
have the right cookies, and they logged in
themselves.
The problem stems from trusting user sessions
and trusting cookies on their own.
So how can you help protect yourself against
cross-site request forgery?
You can verify the origin and the referral
headers of HTTP requests to confirm they actually
come from your website.
These can't be set programmatically in browsers
by JavaScript.
These are not — these can be faked using
other methods, so they're not just a sure-fire
way of protecting against every single attack.
You can also used synchronised tokens or CSRF
tokens, to verify requests have actually come
from a real form of your website.
These tokens are long and pre predictable
unique data generated on your server and placed
into web forms with submissions for form data.
Your server then only accepts a request from
a user if it includes a recent token that's
been generated for that user.
These tokens aren't stored in cookies, they're
stored in the markup of your website, so they
can't be sent in a CS or CSRF attack.
You could use a cookie-to-header tokens which
are similar.
This relies on the JavaScript same-origin
protocol meaning JavaScript can only set HTTP
headers for sites on the same origin.
Finally, this is no defence if your site has
been compromised in any other way, for example,
using cross-site scripting which we're going
to get on t next.
How mad would you be if I changed the slide
now!
[Laughter].
Let's talk about BB code.
BB code was a special language that allowed
you to format text on forums and in your post.
You could use it to insert images of gifs
of your favourite character.
It was intended to be a replacement for HTML,
and a subset, a smaller reduced language,
because validating HTML is a hard job.
Having a reduced language would make it easier
to validate.
You could use it insert your favourite gifs
to your heart's content and this was our idea
of fun back on the early web.
One day, one of my friends found the mismatching
of the opening and closing tags, BB code tags,
allowed you to do weird stuff.
Mismatching tags confused the BB code transcoder
and caused broken HTML to be inserted into
that page.
From there, they were able to insert arbitrary
code into their posts and start executing
JavaScript.
They used this to repeatedly spam the forum
of arrival on — of a rival online game clap
during a match, with their opponents distracted,
they won the match while their forums were
slowly filling up with gobbledygook.
In attack allowed someone to run their code
on your website, which is otherwise known
as cross-site scripting.
This in 2005, he became famous for having
friends — lots and lots, and lots of friends.
He wrote a worm, which is a self-replicating
script that replicates itself across the website.
Like lots of people in 2005, Sammy had a MySpace
page, a limited social network by today's
standards.
You could customise your headline but not
really put much in there.
It was restricted.
It had limited for matting options, and it
allowed you to put 12 profile photos on your
page, but only 12.
If you wanted to add more photos, you had
to take some down.
So Sammy discovered that some tags, like the
div tag and image tag were allowed to be inserted
into content, but the script tag to insert
JavaScript was filtered.
MySpace wasn't about to let people insert
script and run JavaScript on their pages.
MySpace stripped the script back.
Sound's back.
Some browsers executed JavaScript in style
tags.
It's like the browser said, "Here's a div
tag.
Do you want to set a background?
Yes, sure.
What URL do you want to set?
I will have JavaScript, please.
Yes, sure, I will execute that."
So MySpace stripped JavaScript thwarting injection
of scripts into MySpace pages.
It turns out, though, that if you inserted
a line break into the word "JavaScript", the
code would run absolutely fine, and MySpace
would not know.
That is how Sammy got JavaScript into MySpace.
Now he tried to write a script that would
replicate itself across all the pages.
So he could find out new friends by inspecting
the page's source.
So he could find the user IDs of the people
that he wanted to add.
To do this, you would normally use the body.html
property.
MySpace were prepared for people like Sammy
coming.
They filtered this too.
This is not a problem if you concatenate a
string and evaluate it using a eval function.
There is a good reason why a lot of developers
call eval evil.
This trick also works on XML HTTP requests
on ready state change, otherwise known as
Ajax, allowing Sammy to make an HTTP requests
to the MySpace API so he could send friend
requests.
He also found that the API worked on a different
subdomain, the same origin protocol in browsers
forbid him from sending requests to the profile
pages domain, but he discovered that you could
actually view profile pages on the API's domain,
so he just redirected the browser to the other
domain, and it worked fine.
This is the complete code.
There are a few more tricks that Sammy used,
but I've shown you the most interesting ones.
He added this to his profile page, and he
waited.
One hour later, he had a new friend request.
It is starting to work.
Seven hours later, he had 221 friend requests,
and it started to take off.
One hour later, that number has doubled to
480.
It is starting to grow exponentially.
Every friend that he recruits, that also recruits
all of their friend as well be and the total
friend count grows and grows, and grows.
Eight hours later, Sammy has 900,000 friend
requests.
It's now growing so fast that every time Sammy
refreshes the page, thousands more people
are being added to that count.
This is Sammy's actual screen shot showing
the number of friend requests.
One hour later, MySpace collapses under the
load of people requesting to be Sammy's friend.
MySpace eventually recovered and patched the
vulnerability two hours later.
Sammy was raided by the US secret service,
he was sentenced to 90 days community service,
he was only allowed the use of one computer
at not allowed to use the internet, and he
was ordered to pay over $15,000 restitution
to MySpace.
Cross-site scripting allows users to inject
their own code into your site, and some people
believe content injection is a better word
for this, because it is people stuffing their
own HTML, their own CSS, their own images,
into your site, and it's very dangerous.
So how can you help protect yourself from
cross-site scripting?
You can escape user input using on entry using
a library like sanitisation.html.
Don't be attempted to roll your own.
People like MySpace were prepared for people
like Sammy but not prepared enough.
This is really, really difficult to do.
Use an escaping library like React or Angular
templating library.
There are ways around them, but they can be
updated frequently, and they are from convenient
to use but won't save you on their own.
You can implement a content-security policy.
This restricts which domains' content can
be securely loaded from.
Loading content from third parties is very,
very risky, so you want to lock it down to
domains that you absolutely trust.
You can also use the integrity property on
script and link tags.
This allows you to insert a hash into these
tags, and this hash is like a fingerprint
for the resources that you're loading.
If the resource changes, if it has been changed
by someone else in a man-in-the-middle attack,
that fingerprint will change as well.
If the fingerprint doesn't match the resource,
then the browsers can re fuse to load it.
In 1999, the web was like a wild west frontier.
These newly discovered attacks could be used
against pretty much all websites, and it was
just utter chaos.
This is the picture that we still conjure
about web security and about the web.
The truth is, the stakes are higher than they've
ever been now.
This is not just discussing your favourite
characters.
We're now talking about personal data, we're
talking about people's money, and people's
lives.
But I also believe there's never been a better
time to learn about web security.
More and more resources and tools are available
to help you write secure code.
And try not to think of it like a wild west,
but think about it as an adventure play ground.
If you're curious, learning about web security
can be really fun and really, really interesting,
and it need not be really hard.
It's an important topic.
I'm really confident that there really has
never been a better time to learn.
Everyone has to start, and everyone is a beginner
once.
So I want to shout out to all these people
who helped make this talk possible for telling
me stories about the early web.
The names have been changed to protect the
innocent and the guilty.
Thank you very much.
[Cheering and Applause]